Boa noite a todos é um prazer novamente
estar com vocês numa Live para a nossa
comunidade fechada do canal do YouTube
Eu vou discutir dois artigos com vocês
depois nós vamos partir para as
perguntas do
documento Boa noite Eliseu Carlos Marta
e quem esteja assistindo ao vivo à
medida que vocês estejam entrando de um
alô dê um um sinal de que você está na
Live para que eu possa cumprimentar Ok
bem o primeiro ponto que nós vamos
discutir hoje é um estudo intrigante que
investiga a relação entre a gestão de
certas vitaminas eem incidência de pedr
nos
índic então nós sabemos que dieta tem a
ver com formação de cálculos
urinários vamos ver sobre essas
vitaminas e a sua relação com esse mesmo
assunto então o que que foi estudado
Esse estudo analisou se a ingestão de
cetas itamina está associado à
incidência ou não de pedra nos zins e a
pesquisa se focou em nove vitaminas A
vitamina B1 a B2 a B6 a B12 a c a a a d
a e e a k Então os pesquisadores queriam
entender se níveis mais altos de
ingestão dessas vitaminas poderiam
reduzir a chance para uma pedra nos rins
então participaram do estudo 23.000
pessoas cerca de 23000 23.000 pessoas
com a idade média de 48 anos sendo
aproximadamente metade mulheres e outra
metade homens são
54% de mulheres e 46 de homens e todos
os participantes residiam nos Estados
Unidos então era uma amostra Ampla e
diversificada foi um estudo transversal
que utilizou dados do National Health
examination Survey que é n hunes a
ingestão alimentar dos participantes foi
avaliada por meio de dois eh
questionários alimentares de 24 horas
administrados com intervalo de 3 a 10
dias e os participantes também foram
perguntados se já tiveram pedras nos
INSS A análise levou em consideração são
vários fatores de confusão que poderiam
atrapalhar como idade sexo raça índice
massa corporal estado civil nível de
educação estatus de tabagismo se fumava
ou não consumo de álcool e presença de
doenças Então os resultados mostraram
que comparado aos participantes com
menor ingestão aqueles com maior
ingestão de vitamina
B6 vitamina C de casa e vitamina D tá
então B6 C e D de casa tinham
respectivamente 24% 27 e 23% menos
chance desenvolver pé nos então a
vitamina B6 a vitamina C de casa e a
vitamina D protegeram contra a formação
de cálculos urinários análise de dose
resposta indicou que maiores ingestas de
vitamina B6 e vitamina D de dado estavam
Associados a menor probabilidade deção
de pedra nos e para vitamina C a maior
redução de risco foi observada com uma
ingestão de aproximadamente 100 mg por
dia então quantidades superiores a essa
não resultaram em melhorias
adicionais então B6 C e D essas três
vitaminas ajudam a evitar cálculos
urinários e a vitamina C já foi colocada
como vilão e a d também né A D porque
foi acusado de ser uma vitamina que
aumentaria a calcificação dentro do Rim
e a c por acidificar a urina então o
estudo mostra o contrário que as
vitaminas B6 C e D elas são
protetoras no entanto é importante
lembrar que a relação observada não
prova a causalidade tá essa relação que
foi encontrada de as pessoas consumindo
essa vitamina ter menos cálculos não
prova a causalidade porque o estudo é um
estudo trans unsal então mais pesquisas
seriam necessárias para confirmar esses
achados e entender os mecanismos
envolvidos a BC já é uma vitamina antiga
que se fala há muito tempo que protege
contra cálculo urinário os que são aqui
os agentes assim de surpresa vitamina C
e D né não para mim porque eu nunca vi
realmente vitamina C e D provocar
cálculo urinário pelo
contrário Então ajustar sua dieta para
aumentar os níveis de vitamina B6 C e D
pode ser uma estratégia potencialmente
eficaz para reduzir o risco de formação
de pedra nos
rins certo próximo estudo é um estudo
fascinante que compara a eficácia
diferentes enxaguantes bucais no combate
a gingivite então se você tem esse
problema ou conhece alguém com esse
problema se você se preocupa com saúde
bucal Preste atenção no que eu vou falar
aqui então ele eles analisaram a
eficácia de um enxaguante bucal à base
de própolis comparado ao enxaguante
desses que você compra na farmácia né
Listerine etc se pacol que tem
clorexidina e e também compararam com
Placebo então clorexidina Placebo e a
base própolis compararam os três nós
sabemos que própolis é uma substância
resinosa que é produzido pelas abelhas
tem excelentes propriedades
antiinflamatórias antimicrobianas
antioxidantes todos vocês sabem disso e
a clorexidina é um antisséptico muito
utilizado de modo geral até para
cirurgias e é também um antisséptico
usado para tratamento da gingivite Então
quem participou desse estudo foram 45
jovens adultos idade média de 24 anos 29
Mulheres e 16 Homens todos com gengivite
esses participantes foram recrutados na
clínica do ecológica da Universidade
masa na Malásia a diversidade dos
participantes ajudou a garantir que os
resultados fossem aplicáveis a uma ampla
faixa de população então estudo foi
conduzido Em um formato de ensaio
Clínico randomizado de 21 dias onde os
participantes foram divididos em três
grupos o grupo um zou um Chagu bocal com
5% de própolis o grupo dois um
enxaguante bucal com clorexidina e o
três usou placeo então todos os
participantes utilizaram 10 ml do
enxaguante duas vezes ao dia após o café
da manhã e antes de dormir gargarejando
por um minuto Eles foram instruídos a
evitar o álcool o tabaco antibióticos de
uso sistêmico vi oral antibióticos
também de uso local e pastas de dente
contendo agentes antimicrobianos durante
o período de estudo Além disso todos
receberam a mesma marca de escova de
dente e pasta de dente para padronizar o
cuidado oral Quais foram os resultados
então eles mostraram a melhoria nos
índices de placa e gengivite em todos os
três grupos após período de 21 dias tá
os três grupos inclusive o Placebo teve
melhor agora curioso aqui no entanto o
enxaguante bucal com
própolis se destacou apresentando
melhores resultados em comparação grupo
que esou clorexidina e Placebo então
clorexidina também teve um desempenho
melhor que Placebo como se fosse
esperado né então próprios foi melhor do
que a
clorexidina então em resumo o estudo
indica que o enxaguante bucal a base de
própolis pode ser uma alternativa mais
eficaz ao combate de placa e vite em
comparação aos tradicionais enxaguantes
com clorexidina então para quem busca
uma opção natural e potente para
melhorar a saúde bucal própolis pode ser
uma excelente escolha então é
interessante você fazer o uso do
própolis como exaguante
bucal certo hoje tem bastante pergunta
então já vou partir direto paraas
perguntas aqui uma coisa que eu queria
estabelecer com vocês aqui é pra gente
criar um limite de perguntas tá por
pessoa a cada
Live para não ficar muito longo e também
às vezes não ficar desgastante para as
outras pessoas
que não ten interesse naquela as
perguntas em especial tá que que vocês
acham disso a de deixar um limite de
cinco perguntas por Live Ok por pessoa
tá não na Live toda cinco perguntas por
pessoa por Live bem vamos lá vou abrir o
documento e vou dividir com
vocês das
perguntas vou voltar aqui que eu tava
olhando as perguntas vou botar o início
desculpa a barulhada de cachorro porque
essa vizinhança minha aqui tá cada vez
com mais cachorro né Espero que não
tenha
atrapalhando
bem vamos
lá primeira pergunta do Alexandre deixa
eu ampliar um pouco mais t ampliando no
lugar errado aqui aqui que
amplia
ah antes da gente continuar deixa eu dar
um boa noite para enil pro Alexandre
cusis e pra
Eliane me lembro que T lá em Ribeiro
falou em um vídeo antigo a respeito do
aproveitamento e absorção das proteínas
dos alimentos um método chamado nnu net
nitrogen utilization segundo Esse estudo
o ovo tem utilização de 50% o epro tem
16% minha dúvida é se alimentos com nnu
baixo podem sobrecarregar o organismo
devido a baixa utilização E também o que
que o organismo faz com as proteínas que
não são utilizadas Então os alimentos
que T nnu baixo só vão sobrecarregar o
organismo se você tiver utilizando uma
quantidade muito grande Tá você consumir
muita proteína com baixo e nesse caso se
você exagerar consumir uma quantidade
absurda você pode sim resultar numa
sobrecarga do fígado e dos rins o fígado
porque ele Precisa converter as excretas
nitrogenadas de amônia em ureia e o rim
porque o rim vai e descartar esse
nitrogênio e especialmente Isso vai ser
um problema em pessoas com a função
renal
metida tá então como é que essas
proteínas são processadas do organismo
as proteínas têm que ser
desaminados para síntese proteica ou não
são utilizadas para qualquer coisa no
organismo o grupo Amina é
removido o nitrogênio
Vai resultar na formação de amônia que é
rapidamente convertio em urea pelo
fígado Então essa urea transportada pros
rins excretadas na
urina e os esqueletos de carbono que
resultaram da desaminação podem ser
oxidados para produção de energia ou
convertidos em glicose ou ácidos gráo se
o organismo tiver precisando de energia
tá agora vamos usar então a
classificação você já comentou que o ovo
tem o nni de
50% isso eu lembro também que eu quando
eu fui pó isso foi comentado essa
informação que você tá falando procede e
é confirmada o tem tem aproximadamente
16 a 18% como você colocou aí a cas por
volta de
40% agora apesar do ter uma nnu
relativamente baixo ele tem um um bom
perfil de aminoácidos né tem todas as no
aminoácidos essenciais tá então esse nnu
aí é uma coisa que nem todo mundo
considera como tão importante assim tá a
carne vai ter por volta de 32% tanto a
bovina a suina quantro a de aves né ou
de frango o peixe fruto do mar um pouco
menos 28% a soja por volta de
24% feijão e outras leguminosas por
volta de
20% só que o perfil aí é menos
equilibrado de aminoácido os cereais
como arroz trigo e aveia por volta de
16% tá E os vegetais folhosos em torno
de 12 a
14% Ok então essa que é a
classificação desses
grupos lembrando a todos vocês que
estejam ao vivo podem interagir comigo e
perguntar algo se não entenderam a
resposta pergunta algum um detalhe que
vocês queiram
esclarecer Boa noite Marilda que entrou
também agora pergunta da Marta qual sua
opinião sobre o uso de tacrina para
melhora de motivação e foco acha que é
seguro sim eu acho bem seguro até AC
crina tem uma estrutura parecida com
cafeína Só que não dá aquela situação
muito comum de você ficar agitado quando
você toma muito Cafeína que você fica
Jump né fica naquela situação que isso
aqui parece que virou espuleta demais e
fica irritado
né ô até muito interessante ela melhora
energia motivação sem dar aquele excesso
de de irritação do da
cafeína aumenta o foco e a concentração
reduz a
fadiga a dose é segura em até 200 mg por
dia alguns usuários relatam efeitos
colaterais leves como náusea dor de
cabeça insônia então é possível ter
insônia com a tacrina não é comum quanto
com a cafeína Mas é possível além de
nusa e dor de
cabeça Lógico que a resposta é
tolerância pode variar entre indivíduo e
outro e existe potencial de interação em
até clina com outros medicamentos ou
suplementos estimulantes tá então tem
que presta atenção nisso
então de modo geral tecina é bem segura
tá então mas você tem que testar a sua
sensibilidade
individual
próximo Eliane pergunta Eliane beluco tá
ao vivo aí pelo que eu vi vale a pena
usar quercetin Max cit ou ou cureit não
sei como é que eles pronunciam em
relação a que cetina com enz k1 e
cucumina excelente pergunta viu Elane a
disponibilidade realmente é maior ou se
trata somente de
marketing Eu sempre tenho essa pulga
atrás da orelha para te falar a verdade
tá mas a princípio esses produtos Sim
são fidedignos são produtos corretos são
produtos que não é só marketing e todos
eles têm mecanismos aí tecnológicos para
aumentar sorção e a biodisponibilidade
no caso do
quetim ela é uma quetin em
nanoemulsão combinado a fosfolipídeos né
é uma gretina em
nanoemulsão e isso facilitaria a
absorção Ok então ela seria mais
absorvível do que acetina tradicional O
Max é bem semelhante também Max é também
uma forma de o
[Música]
binol que também tem essa essa forma de
nanoemulsão para aumentar no caso eles
chamam de lipossomas mas o conceito é o
mesmo de nanoemulsão né são pequenas
esferas de gordura que aumentam a
absorção do do
produto o kirit assim como também o
cucuí que eu uso mais é uma forma
patenteada de curcumina de alta
biodisponibilidade e também tem algumas
tecnologias como fossas nanoemulsão ou
micela que é a mesma coisa que lipossoma
também para aumentar
absorção Então realmente valeria a pena
se você tiver os recursos para comprar
esse produto são mais
caros certo mas para todo mundo talvez
paraas pessoas mais doentes valeria a
pena pagar mais pela
absorção maior e a biodisponibilidade
maior pessoas mais
saudáveis estão fazendo prevenção
poderiam estar utilizando as formas mais
simples aí né sem ser a Palma de alta
absorção e alta
biodisponibilidade próxima pergunta
Elian excesso de ômega-3 pode elevar o
colesterol é verdade que só se beneficia
do ômega-3 quem tem problemas
cardiovasculares não o ômega3 tem efeito
antiinflamatório de fato ele vai
aumentar o HDL mas vai aumentar um pouco
o LDL colesterol também mas ele vai
aumentar a parte do LDL que não vai
oxidar ele vai aumentar a partícula de
LDL que não vai ser aquela fração que
vai oxidar e vai parar na parede do vaso
para entupir a parede do vaso tá então
aumenta o HDL aumenta o LDL E baixa o
triglicéride isso que é o mais
importante do ômega-3 só que o ômega3
além de ser um agente antiinflamatório
não é só saúde cardiovascular ele vai
atuar também como eu já falei na redução
da inflamação na melhora da Saúde da
parede das
artérias e também vai ajudar na função
cerebral todos vocês sabem aí do ômega-3
dha né que é importante pro cérebro pros
olhos também né vai ajudar a prevenir a
degeneração macular e paraa saúde das
articulações e também importante pro
intestino para bar carreira intestinal
então omega3 tem várias funções não é só
cardiovascular não né Eh eu sei que saiu
um artigo aí falando que ômega-3 não
teria benefício para que não tem
problema cardiovascular mas esse artigo
para mim tá artigo foi feito de maneira
inadequada próxima
pergunta Marilda em que quantidade a
frequência bendas é tóxico para o
fígado então se você usar um bendazol
por mais de 30 dias que nem faz sentido
né que uso um bendazol eh C dias no
máximo 7 dias no máximo Então há mais de
30 dias de uso e uma dose acima de 800
MG por dia Poderia gerar essa
hepatotoxicidade Lembrando que pessoas
que têm já doença hepática já tem uma
debilidade nesse órgão pode ter essa
toxicidade com doses mais baixas
e os sintomas de toxicidade seria
aumento das enzimas do fígado né a TJ
TGP e a gama AGT a fosfatas alcalina
pode subir também icterícia que é o
amarelamento da pele dos olhos fadiga
dor abdominal e náusea são são sintomas
mais
comuns Ok então seria doses acima de 800
MG por dia ou uso acima de 30 dias então
é bem seguro nas doses habituais
essas dosas que eu tô falando é muito
incomum Na verdade eu nunca
vi Marilda seguindo no mesmo assunto do
Duomo e tá da lafila se usar os dois
juntos aumentar a propriedade de
facilitar
mixão geralmente sim geralmente você vai
ter um aumento aí da do relaxamento
músculos do colo da bexiga e da próstata
Vai facilitar a mixão a união dos dois
muita gente inclusive usa os dois juntos
tá eu para alguns pacientes eu prescrevo
essa combinação
sim então eles vão ter a o efeito
sinérgico vão melhorar o fluxo urinário
mais do que se fossem osados
isolados Porém tem um risco aí de
hipotensão Ok você pode acontecer da
pessoa ficar com pressão baixa eh se ela
tiver tendência porque os dois podem
baixar a pressão
arterial isso pode inclusive levar
desmaios em algumas pessoas tem que
tomar cuidado também com a interação com
outros medicamentos que a pessoa pode
estar
tomando Ok mas de modo geral paraa
maioria das pessoas essa combinação
funciona
bem não quis comparar a dose de zinco
que cobre na pergunta da Live passada e
sem perguntar porque é recomendado como
necessário uso concomitante de cobre com
zinco Nem sempre tá Marildo é porque
assim são dois pontos diferentes tá eh a
questão deles competirem na absorção não
não quer dizer que eles não possam ser
utilizados na mesma pessoa eh você pode
usar forma quelada ou melhor ainda usar
em horários diferentes aí você já
resolve o problema mas também não é
obrigatório usar sempre os dois juntos
se você tiver uma pessoa que tá com
zinco alto e o cobre baixo dá somente
cobre porque aí esse cobre ele vai
tender a reduzir o zinco que tá alto
mesma coisa se o cobre
tiver baixo e o zinco alto você pode dar
cobre e é isoladamente porque aí você
vai estar compensando você vai est
e repondo o cobre e tendendo a reduzir o
zinco na pessoa agora se os dois tiverem
baixos a tem que repor os dois juntos
Ficou claro Marilda Ficou claro você tá
ao vivo se você tiver qualquer dvida
mais me pergunta mas não é contraditório
isso tá o fato deles competir entre si
não é contraditório a competição é só na
absorção não é na na utilização do
organismo você entendeu os dois são
necessários para organismo não tem
competição dentro no organismo a
competição é só na
absorção o que que é
indicado suplementar em mulheres de 33
anos que tem retina menor que
50 primeiro tem que ver se tem que repor
mesmo né porque às vezes não precisa se
eh dependendo da situação se for parente
com câncer mesmo a Ferritina não é bom
deixar muito alta não Ok mas vamos dizer
que que a pessoa tá com fadiga e tudo
mais aí você pode usar várias foras de
suplementação você pode usar o ferro na
forma ferrosa né que tem três tipos aí O
sulfato o gluconato
fumarato esses três são bem comuns
sulfato gluconato e fumarato você pode
usar polimaltose férica que é a forma do
ferro
férrico e você pode usar que eu gosto
mais de usar o suplemento junto com a
vitamina C que ajuda a absorver o
ferro
certo então tem várias formas de você
suplementar esse ferro aí tem várias
suplementações o fato de Ferro o
gluconato de Ferro o fumarato férrico a
polimaltose férrica e a o férro com
vitamina
C Então pessoal eu já falei várias vezes
isso eu entendo que vocês queiram que eu
analise exame de paciente mas não é
adequado para esse formato que nós temos
aqui tá eu vou falar em termos Gerais eu
não vou falar nesse caso específico aqui
porque eu não posso dar essa orientação
e ficar vendo valores de exames em live
ok porém se você for ver de uma forma
geral mulheres podem repor testosterona
não recomendo que façam isso sem repor
também estrogênio e a progesterona junto
tem relatos de que mulheres repond
testosterona de forma isolada pode dar
aterosclerose então é melhor que use
junto com os outros dois hormônios
importantes pra mulher a forma mais
comum é o gel transdérmico ou creme
transdérmico as doses mais comuns de 05
a 2 MG
por dia na pele eu acho que é melhor
paraa mulher o mais fisiológico É
possível usar adesivos transdérmicos
adesivos que cola na pele que vão
liberar em média 300 microg por dia de
testosterona porém esses adesivos podem
causar irritação na
pele eu não falei da desvantagem do
creme transdérmico Mas pode também
transferir para outras pessoas é uma
desvantagem
considerável injeção intramuscular que
eu não recomendo não ser que seja mulher
atleta aí você pode usar de 50 a 100 mg
da testosterona base a cada duas
semanas mas é um pico que dá né Toda a
injeção de testosteron dá pico dá aquele
coice de testosteron na mulher se ela
for uma mulher muito ativa fisicamente
atleta até vale a pena mas eu acho um
pouco fisiológico pra maioria das
mulheres e tem os pellets né tem os
implantes subcutâneos que tá na moda aí
de alguns anos e queem mulheres
Geralmente os 75 a 150 MG do implante
ele Dura Por volta de 3 meses no máximo
6 meses a não ser o implante lá que usa
o páso que são implantes que duram um
ano né que é aquele implante do osimar
cotinho que gerou outras empresas depois
que ele faleceu então S essas formas de
de uso de testosterona em mulheres tá eu
prefiro o uso do gel
transdérmico e tem que tomar cuidado
porque tem mulheres que vão converter
muito testosterone HT que é AD do
testosterone E se ela tiver tendência
ela vai ter alopécia androgenética ela
vai cair cabelo né outros efeitos
colaterais comuns é acne muito comum em
mulher oleos na pele pode também
aparecer pelos em lugares indesejados
pode alterar voz pode aumentar o
clitores se for excessivo a dose né
nesse caso Então tem que ficar atento a
esses efeitos colaterais aí e algumas
mulheres podem até engordar em chá ou
conversão excessiva da testosterona em
estrogênio também pode acontecer
também Marilda quando a insulina é acima
de seis ela deve ser reduzida mesmo que
a hemoglobina glicada esteja menor que
4,9 depende Mario Na verdade eu
colocaria esse limite como 10 não como
seis tá e o ideal é a insulina entre
quatro e seis Tá mas eu coloco como
limite para tratamento 10 agora fez uma
medida só de insulina e deu seis e a
glicada tá
4,9 eu não trataria não mas se for uma
pessoa que tá tendo silin acima de 10
direto comog agada baixa trataria Tá
novamente Eu Tô analisando de modo geral
isso aqui não Tô analisando exame de
ninguém tá se você não pode tomar essa
essa informação que tô falando agora
para casos específicos Tô dando uma
orientação geral Ok evitem de mandar
resultado exames por favor por esse
canal por
favor o que se usa para diminuir a
insulina a mesma coisa que a gente usa
para diminuir o carboidrato ou baixar
glicose a dieta é fundamental uma dieta
com redução de carboidrato refinado
processado industrializados aumentar o
consumo de fibras comer uma dieta com
baixo índice glicêmico incluindo
gorduras saudáveis na dieta uma dieta
alarb ou cetogênica o consumo de
proteína é fundamental para ajudar na
saciedade também para ajudar a pessoa a
consumir menos carboidrato e evitar
comer tarde da noite também importante
exercício físico né tanto exercício
aeróbico quanto treinamento de força de
resistência importante o hit também que
você alterna a intensidade da corrida ou
da bicicleta bem interessante para
ajudar a aumentar a sensibilidade
insulina e os suplementos que a gente
usa para ajudar né
berberina picolinato de cromo vanádio
acido afico magnésio ajuda ômega3 ajuda
Ok controle do estresse também
gerenciamento do Sono tudo isso ajuda a
baixar a insulina tá tudo que baixa a
glicose também ajuda a baixar a insulina
ou consequência
para prostatite crônica a indicação de
ctina é de 500 mg duas vezes ao dia sim
você pode usar essa dose de 500 mg duas
vezes ao
dia nada impede também de aumentar essa
dose para até 2 g ao dia ela ajuda
bastante ela tem efeito antiinflamatório
antistamínico
tem propriedades também deor dos
sintomas urinários
antioxidante então é uma é uma boa
alternativa na Live passada eu
recomendei bromexina não você confundiu
bromexina com bromelina tá bromelina é
enzima do
abacaxi tá é uma enzima digestiva que
ajuda também quebrar imunocomplexo no
sangue Tá mas por acaso você acertou
mirou no pato e acertou no no Ganso né
porque eu nem sabia fui pesquisar a
bromexina que a gente usa muito como
agente mucolítico né para usou bastante
no covid também para tratar doenças
respiratórias quebrar muco facilitar a
expectoração eu não sabia mas pode ser
utilizada sim para prostatite
crônica porque tem ação antiinflamatória
e ajuda a quebrar as secreções
prostáticas reduzindo viscosidade e
também facilitando a
drenagem então pode ser até utilizado
Mas o que eu falei na Live foi bromelina
tá não foi bromexina
não bromexina você poderia utilizar 8 MG
três vezes ao dia se fosse a bromelina
seria 200 mg
tá o que fazer para DIU os prováveis
malefícios dos antibióticos e
antiinflamatórios primeira coisa é
evitar usar né só usar a comum caso que
realmente você não tem o que fazer por
exemplo eu vou fazer minhas
musculaçãorotinas
[Música]
p é tentar levar a dor com gelo né com
massagem mas vamos então dizer que você
foi obrigado a usar o antibiótico depois
de usar antibiótico usar um probiótico e
um prebiótico para restabelecer a flora
intestinal você pode usar por exemplo os
mais famosos probióticos são lactoba os
rinos e o sacaromise bulard são muito
usados pós uso de antibiótico para
tentar melhorar a flora intestinal
prebiótico é melhor ainda mais
importante porque são as fibras que
fazem as bactérias crescerem que elas
comem essas fibras é a comida da
bactéria e entre elas Temos vários tem
FZ gos tem inulina tem alcachofra tem
que mais
Acácia tem alho cebola aspargo banana o
cachorro tudo isso tem eh
prebióticos que vão ajudar as
bactérias a crescer já tá rico em fibras
obviamente né também vai ajudar
hidratação adequada e eh para caso de
antiinflamatório usar o mínimo de tempo
possível e se tiver problema com o
estômago dor de estômago usar protetor
gástrico né protetor gástrico você pode
usar tanto os prazois da vida como
sucralfato ou até mesmo a Ranitidina
para ajudar a não ter problema no estô e
se você puder usar antiinflamatório
natural no lugar ômega-3 própolis
cúrcuma gengibre é melhor ainda né em
vez de utilizar o antiinflamatório
convencional se hidratar bem também
gente protege os seus rins né do efeito
ruim dos antiinflamatórios não
esteroidais esse tipo de
antiinflamatório de fassa deeno de
clofenac misul etc eles atacam muito o
rim o fígado e o estômago tá não tem que
proteger os zinos tomando bastante água
Então é
isso próxima
pergunta a empresa nutrimentos que você
recomendou há vários anos lá no Spotify
parou de vender suplementos na Nal Foods
e passou a fabricar os seus próprios eu
não conheço tá Eliseu esses próprios aí
atualmente eles fabricam e vende
suplemento intimate performance você
aprova e recomenda eu fui ver os
ingredientes são bons tá se for de boa
qualidade eu não põe minha mão no fogo
que eu não sei se é seria um bom
suplemento porque tem AL arginina tem
Tribulus tem maca tem jinzen tem zinco e
Marapuama Seria uma boa combinação Tá
mas eu não
posso P minha mão no fogo porque eu tem
anos que eu não falo com o pessoal da
nutrimentos aí e não sei se eles foram
atrá os melhores fornecedores
quando alguém engraxa sapato na
rua quei uma pergunta Pera
aí Ah não é tem a segunda pergunta aqui
sempre pensei que o Zin fosse o melhor
suplemento que tem para prevenir gripe
Mas você falou na Live que usa Glutamina
mas o fato de usar Glutamina não quer
dizer que Z não é bom os dois são bons
né se você trocar Glutamina pelo zinco
também consegue prevenir por que que eu
vou trocar se eu posso adicionar
elizu eu uso a Glutamina porque ela para
mim é boa pro intestino e boa para a
recuperação muscular pós treino e para
evitar de gripar quando eu faço muito
aeróbico para isso que eu uso Glutamina
para mim o Glutamina nesse ponto para
esse objetivo é mais eficiente que o
zinco
né mas pode muito bem usar o o Zino
também J Glutamina o Zico é importante
pro sistema imune paraas células natural
Killer ela reduz a duração da gripe
quando você pega a
gripe ela atrapalha a replicação de
vários vírus tomar cuidado só que o
zinco pode dar dor de estômago e não
pode tomar excesso de
zinco Tá então não é uma coisa
contraditória não você pode usar os dois
se for o caso
para mim a gramina mais eficiente para
esse caso que eu tenho de tendência a
gripar quando eu tô fazendo muito
exercício quando alguém graxa sapato na
rua a graxa contamina o corpo se você
não tiver contato direto com a gracha
não só se você tiver pondo a mão em cima
da Graxa e se isso acontecer você tem
que lavar a mão logo em seguida tá a
graxa ela tem solventes como
tetracloroetileno nafta benzina que são
prejudiciais saúde mas eh se você não
ficar tocando na gracha você não vai ter
problemas e se tocar você simplesmente
lava a
pele se você se expor de
forma limitada e ocasional a gracha de
sapato não vai ser uma contaminação
expressiva
tá então é importante que você tome
cuidado não fique pondo a mão na graxa à
toa alguns estudos indicam que a
absorção pela pele de sorvetes orgânicos
como eu falei aí a benzina a nafta e o
tetracloro
tilen pode causar problema de saúde mas
geralmente não leva alterações hormonais
tá eles não são disruptores endócrinos
Até onde eu sei
Talvez seja em altas doses né mas você
não vai ficar se expondo de maneira
exagerada a
grax parece que a partir dos 60 anos de
idade se faz necessária a revolução de
testosterona por toda a vida será que
não há exatamente nada que o homem de 60
a 100 anos possa fazer para manter em
1000 esquece número Eliseu o número não
é tão assim essencial não tem gente que
tem testosteron de 900 que tá com
disfunção eré o outro com de 700 600 não
tá toma cuidado com o número
ok Você pode fazer para tentar minimizar
a necessidade de reposição é ter um
estilo de vida saudável
eh fazer atividade física regular
exercício de força dormir bem gerenciar
o estress manter o zinco no sangue
adequado manter o magnésio no sangue
adequado manter a vitamina D do sangue
adequada consumir as gorduras saudáveis
especialmente abacate azeite de oliva
nos e castanhas também as gorduras
monoinsaturadas e também as
ômega-3 não comer alimentos
processados fazer o rit como eu já
comentei não ficar gordo não fumar não
beber não se expor toxinas como é o caso
de bisfenol a f talato e outros aí né
inspetores
endócrinos eem alguns casos você pode
usar suplementos naturais que aumento a
testosterona como é o caso da
Chaga também ajuda a aumentar é o caso
do Veno grego do Tribulus é o caso do de
várias outras
substâncias exame terando pelo sang é
confiável sim é confiável só deixa de
ser confiável quando você tá fazendo a
reposição por transdérmico aí você tem
que fazer pela saliva para poder ter
certeza que a dose que você tá usando é
adequada
só nessa situação que a testosterona
pelo sangue não é não seria confiável
pessoas que estão repondo com hormônio
pela pele
transdérmico fazendo exame de
testosterona pel pelo sangue três vezes
ao dia não faz sentido ninguém faz isso
Eliseu só se fosse tudo científico e na
verdade a maioria das pessoas mede de
manhã cedo que no caso 23 das pessoas é
o período que vai ter o pico de
testosterona no sangue madrugada e manhã
cedo tá se você por acaso um dia fazer
isso que eu duvido que você vai fazer
você pode tirar a média sim eh dos três
resultados 1/3 dos homens T pico de
testosterona à tarde e pode ter então o
resultado falseado se colher de manhã
cedo esse seis Eu já respondi no seu
vídeo propaganda que você fez na jolivi
sobre o curso testosterona no qual você
usava atno lembro que você disse que
entre o jovem e idoso existem apenas as
três diferenças não vou lembrar que que
é as três diferenças
Eliseu Desculpa era o roteiro deles lá
eu não eu não tô com isso na minha
cabeça
não isso aqui é a repetição da pergunta
anterior
perí acho que eu pulei outra coisa aqui
também pera
aí não não pulei
não vamos lá então vinagre de maçã em
gel e também comprimido sub lingual tem
os mesmos benefícios do vinagre de maçã
líquido eu acredito que vai ser menos
quantidade de ácido
acético e também de ád
eu usaria o vinagre de
maçã sabe normal e só usaria o gel
comprimido em caso assim de você não
tolerar o uso do vinagre ou que você tá
na rua e e não é prático carregar o
vinagre após o comprimento subing maçã
se dissolver completamente eu tenho que
fazer bochecho é bom você dar uma
enxaguada na boca não precisa fazer não
precisa fazer bochecho é só você P um
pouco de água na boca enxaguar uma
colher de sopa de vinagre maçã líquido
equivale a quantos comprimidos
sublinguais depende da concentração do
comprimido você teria que conversar com
a Farma e manipulação para saber tá
então não dá para fazer a conta sem
saber a concentração que tem no
comprimido de 500 mg uma colher de sopa
de vinagre de maçã líquido equivale a
quantos gel mesma situação tem que
conversar com a farmácia
comprei o suplemento melatonina n Foods
embora eu não tenha removido aquele
algodão que fica dentro do pote
comprimido esfarela é a melatonina tem
esfarelar vi tive esse problema com
melatonina manipulada aqui em casa por
que acontece isso é pelo método de
fabricação da
melatonina eu acredito que o método de
fabricação dela é uma maneira que acaba
disfar relando a absorção de
humidade pode aumentar
eh essa questão do dos dos
filamento Mas você falou que você não
tirou o algodão que tava dentro do do
pote
[Música]
né mas oscilações de temperatura também
podem est sendo parcialmente
responsáveis aí pelo esfarelamento alta
temperatura pode afetar a integridade
comprimidos pode ser problema de
transporte também às vezes pode est
contribuindo para esse
farelo Então tem que procurar manter os
comprimos no lugar seco e fresco fechar
bem o pote né usar de maneira
cuidadosa e conversar com o fabricante
ou com a farmácia né se isso acontecer
saber quais foram os potenciais
problemas num farmá de manipulação
disseram que fazem suplemento betaína e
e clorit betaína eh porém com 4 meses de
validade Geralmente as manipulações
trabalham com 90 dias de de validade a
maioria dos itens tá isso tem a ver que
eles não usam não usam muito
conservantes mas eu já cansei de tomar
remédio vencido de farmácia e
manipulação nunca tive problema
obviamente eu não recomendo que você
faça isso se o a cápsula o comprimido
tiver
[Música]
deteriorado agora os os suplementos e
remédios de farmácia comum geralmente
duram muito mais porque eles T mais
conservantes e pelo método de fabricação
também a está sem receita fá manipulação
que fizesse
suplemento qualidade betaína mas pepsina
a ftica ficou com medo de fazer porque
diz ela pepsina é uma enzima
medicamentosa sem pensei que pepsina
fosse nutriente pepsina é uma enzima na
verdade não é
considerado fármaco tá pepsina é química
é é química mas é química
natural você recomenda fag de
manipulação
fif recomendo você comenda bi galenos a
Bi galenos Eu não conheço tão
bem suplemento glicina só avisa os
efeitos negativos da pessoa que não
conseguiu dormir sim a glicina tem
efeito
calmante ela ajuda a dormir sim tem
estudos mostrando que 2 g de glicina à
noite
ajudam a
dormir ele tem um efeito neuroprotetor a
glicina também funciona como
neurotransmissão calmante no
cérebro ajuda a regular a temperatura
corporal reduz a fadiga durante o dia
alivia o estresse e a glicina e a lisina
são bons aminoácidos calmantes do
cérebro junto com a com gaba né
e teve um estudo também que mostrou que
a glicina pode melhorar a memória e o
desempenho cognitivo após uma noite de
sono
insuficiente tá então a glicina nos
estudos americanos é 2 A 3 G que eles
utilizam no Brasil Geralmente as doses
são mais
baixas se uma pessoa dificilmente fica
estressada e vive tranquila o dia todo
ela pode ingerir os suo est chagando
somente na hora de dormir pode ingerir
por volta de meia hora ou uma hora antes
de dormir que vai ajudar assim na
qualidade de
sono então se for para sono usar por
volta de 1 hora antes dormir você pode
usar no no mínimo meia hora antes dormir
tá agora se você quiser ter mais energia
durante o dia você pode usar também a
chaga duas vezes ao dia eh por exemplo
de manhã e de tarde você pode utilizar
dessa forma ou uma dose de manhã uma
dose à
noite 20 minutos antes de dormir não é o
melhor horário eu já expliquei isso
agora é verdade que quem tem falta de
ferro sente um desejo estranho de comer
Barro Terra gelo e come mesmo Sim essa
condição chama-se [ __ ] tá tem esse nome
feio mas esse é o nome oficial nome
científico é [ __ ] e é comum sim a
deficiência de ferro pode levar ao
desenvolvimento dessa estranha vontade
de comer essas coisas esquisitas
aí alimentos enriquecidos com ferro são
úteis sim são úteis sim
ajudam especialmente populações
vulneráveis que que não tem acesso a
alimentos de alta
qualidade então ah só que existe alguns
cereais matinais que eles usam ferro
inadequado
para isso aconteceu muitoos Estados
Unidos e outros países aí então tem que
tomar cuidado com isso porque alguns
cereais matinais enriquecidos com ferrou
ferro
inadequado Mas é uma forma válida metar
gestão de Ferro em populações carentes e
vulneráveis
né os médicos convencionais sabem
prescrever a reposição de Ferro
geralmente sabem
não tem maiores dificuldades em relação
a isso não
[Música]
tá magnésio tronado tem que ser dose
alta a dose alta é porque a molécula do
treonato é muito grande Tá eh não é
porque por outro motivo não é porque a
quantidade de magnésio por molécula é
pequeno comparado com treonato treonato
é uma molécula muito grande então acaba
tendo que tomar dose mais alta para usar
a quantidade adequada de magnésio
não é tanto pela absorção Mas pelo
tamanho da
molécula e ela pode interferir com ferro
também é só tomar em horários diferentes
tá não vai prejudicar os níveis de Ferro
do seu corpo se você tomar em horários
diferentes o biquin corri disfunção
mitocondrial provocado pelo excesso de
Ferro o binol é bom para mitocôndria de
modo geral a disfunção mitocondrial mas
não é específico paraa disfunção causado
pelo excesso de Ferro
tá excesso de ferro pode provocar
diabetes tipo um geralmente ele pode
aumentar o risco de diapet Tipo dois não
Tipo um o suplemento oxalobacter
formigenes que se alimenta do Oxalato no
intestino pode prevenir deficiência de
Ferro desconheço isso tá
não não tem essa informação acho que
não a deficiência de Ferro causado por
Oxalato é mais tratada pela redução da
ingestão de alimentos ricos em Oxalato
do que pelo aumento da ingestão de
ferro pode repor ferro quando estiver
doente lógico pode contanto que tem
indicação de repor o ferro e com
Orientação médica né
bem Vamos às perguntas ao vivo
bioressonância
confiável Eliseu é uma pergunta muito
difícil de responder isso aí
ah eu tô com essa dúvida na minha cabeça
já há muitos anos tá tem muita gente que
eu admiro que eu respeito que uso a
bioressonância eu não me M confortável
para usar o que eu gosto de fazer na
minha vida no meu consultório é medicina
funcional Eu Acredito que para algumas
pessoas é confiável eu conheço algumas
pessoas que usam a biorressonância em si
próprias e já chegaram conclusões
interessantes eu acho que ferramenta de
consultório é um pouco complicado pode
dar resultados bastante díspares de
pessoa para pessoa de profissional para
profissional eu não gosto de usar bioron
para as minhas
condutas eu acho que é mais aplicável a
pessoa aprender para si própria para ela
testar se aquele alimento é bom para ela
testar se a dose x de medicamento é boa
ou se a dose Y é melhor eu acho que
ferramenta de consultório eu não gosto
muito eu acho que é muito
eh variável os resultados tinha um
aparelho lá na clínica que era de
biorressonância que era o PR eu não
gostei dos resultados desse par eu parei
de
usar e também não gostei de algumas
atitudes da da empresa que vende esse
equipamento
aí de representantes nessa empresa
dormir às 21 horas e ac das duas bem
disposto cheio de energia tem algum
problema Creio que não mas eu acho que é
pouco tempo de
sono eu acho pouco tempo de sono mas tem
algumas pessoas que alegam que conseguem
fazer isso por longos períodos de tempo
tempo bedo lingual melatonina sub
lingual engir juntos competem na
absorção Que eu saiba não mas eu eu
faria separado eu usaria um depois o
outro é verdade que aa peruana anal fund
é Ultra concentrada
Ultra Talvez seja muito né concentrada
assim tá equivale a outro comprimisso da
marca piron de outras marcas isso é mais
propaganda viu Eliseu Mas assim é uma
marca de boa qualidade sim mas foi
pessoal do nutrimentos que vê com essa
história aí mas é mais propaganda isso
daí senti um pouco de dor de cabeça
alguma dica fique bem hidratada Marta
Mas você pode dar mais informações aí
que eu será que eu perdi alguma outra
coisa você falou antes meio falar de
contexto né isso daí
né
Eh se eu assisti o vídeo Dr anre Ortiz
sobre a Ivete Não acho que não se sim
tem informações mais sobre dosagens e
tempo de
uso Me manda a fonte miquinha por favor
desse vídeo onde é que você viu isso tá
eu acho que eu não vi não tô lembrado
Mas se você puder mostrar o link a
fonte a dieta já é boa tanto que a
glicose é baixa apenas a insulina que é
mais alta Olha a insulina responde a
glicose Marilda não tem como a insulina
tá alta com glicose baixa o contrário
pode acontecer tem pessoas que tem
falência pancreática de células betas e
aí a glicose sobe a insulina não sobe
junto mas eu não vejo insulina alta com
glicose
baixa se a insulina tá alta é porque
realmente está consumindo eh excesso de
carboidrato usar ácido clorídrico
conjunto com antibióticos É verdade que
melhora muito a digestão
do antibiótico você quer
saber não sei dessa estratégia viu mas
se funciona para
você não vejo porque não utilizar mas eu
nunca li isso em lugar nenhum
não é fácil para essa má manipulação
adquiria a tecnologia lipossomal não não
é fácil a tecnologia muito cara não é
fácil
não na verdade não é a manipulação que
tem a tecnologia tá quem tem tecnologia
é o fornecedor
que manda pra famá manipulação então
esses ativos que você perguntou acho que
foi você que perguntou
cucv o curit Né o
quercetin o próprio a coenzima que de
aut absorção lá o fugiu o nome agora
esses daí eles vêm já do fabricante com
essa tecnologia não é na manipulação que
é feito a essa tecnologia
entendeu sim a chag é uma adaptógeno ele
ajuda a acalmar o cérebro e a controlar
os níveos de
cortisol no caso da insulina 6 Eu já
falei Marilda a insulina 6 não é ruim tá
E é é de quatro a seis o ideal tá a
gente considera ruim acima de 10 tá de
nada sobre até a crina
ah dor de cabeça da tacrina é
isso bebe mais água e diminui a dose da
tacrina essa dica que eu daria tá se é o
que entendi a
pergunta Dr anel está no
grupo Interessante não sabia não mas
também me mostra o vídeo para eu dar uma
olhada mas é fato da a hemoglobina agada
estar 4,9
6,2 Não entendi que que fato do
quê esses números estão bons Marilda tá
não fica Secada com isso não tá
eh senti um pouco de dor de cabeça até
acina alguma dica a dica de beber mais
água e reduzir a dose tá você deve ser
mais sensível que a maioria das
pessoas o link gente evita de jogar as
coisas soltas assim na tenta não tenha
preguiça de escrever não
tá melor també mesmo farelado tem os
mesmos
efeitos acredito que sim não tem nada a
ver com oxidação
não de nada Marilda desculpa
Marta bem vou encerrar pessoal tem uma
hora de Live já ok
Vamos tentar deixar cinco perguntas pro
Live para pessoa tá para todo mundo
poder fazer pergunta e não ficar
monopolizando em duas pessoas ou é
lógico se tiver tem aí dezenas de
pessoas no grupo se só duas pessoas
fizer pergunta vou responder as
perguntas mas é bom que a gente possa
ter oportunidade aí de responder
perguntas de v mais pessoas né Se as
pessoas estão interessadas em fazer
perguntas obrigado então por vocês terem
participado dessa essa Live e nós nos
vemos na próxima um grande abraço um
beijo no coração de vocês